So thank you for coming today. What, um,
what I loved most and the book is how
authentic and how vulnerable you were,
which I feel like when someone's
writing about their life,
they don't always want to write about
the scary or sad or other parts of it.
And I liked that you win fair
with us in the book. So what,
why did you decide to take that kind of
route and not make it be all like roses
and fairy tales?
Roses and fairy tales,
not real life and it's boring.
Um,
it was scary to make the decision to be
so open and vulnerable, but I just felt,
I feel like it's the
only way people relate.
And it's something I discovered a long
time ago on a spin bike and I started to
talk about personal things up there. I
wouldn't make it subjective. I would,
I would say things in a way that it would
apply to everybody and everyone would
immediately relate to what I was saying
and get a lot out of it and know that
all the challenges that we face every day,
we're not alone,
that we're all facing
them kind of together.
What made you ready to write the memoir?
So a lot of people throughout
the years always would say to me,
he knew they would hear my
story and they would say,
you really need to write a book. And
I would just say, Oh yeah, you know,
never thinking would ever happen.
And it really just took one person who
said the same thing and then I said,
yeah, yeah. And kind of dismissed
it. And he said, no, no,
you really need to write a book and I'm
going to introduce you to a literary
agent,
you know,
and basically help pulled me and held
my hand and took me to meet this couple.
And they are literary agents and I sat
in their living room and they said,
tell me your story.
And I did.
And by the time I got home I
had a contract in my inbox.
So that's how it happened. And what
made you, the way you wrote it?
I really liked it. You, you'd shared
personal things and you offer,
made it about how you started two
businesses and all the lessons that you
learned in it and then you split
it into three parts. What made you,
which were a reinvention,
rejuvenation and rewards.
Why did you decide to break it into these
parts and kind of make it a personal
thing and also throw in the business
aspect and lessons that you learned?
I think that,
well first of all,
the reinvention piece is a
huge part of the story and um,
which is why I devoted a whole section
to it because I have had a lot of
roadblocks along the way.
It was not an easy ride by any means,
um, to get to being the cofounder
of both businesses. But, um,
I wanted people to know and understand
and be inspired because no matter where
we are in life, we do all have the ability
to reinvent ourselves if we want to.
And I started soul cycle when I was 48
and I started fly with them when I was
52.
So you know,
a lot of people shocked at that and they
can't even imagine starting a business
at those ages.
But I wanted to tell the story and let
people know that anything's possible.
Um,
so rejuvenation came from
just that starting over again,
starting over again after you've
been burned or hurt or, um,
blindsided and knowing that you can
pick yourself up and start again.
Um, what was the last part?
Reward for words? Yes. I mean,
obviously for me it was just about,
as I say in the subtitle of the book,
it was just about kind of reaping
rewards from this career that,
uh,
I made for myself.
Never ever fathoming that
I would be here today.
Um, never went to business school, had,
didn't have a clue about how to run
a business. Um, and really it just,
it literally all came out
of following my passion.
And you started as a dancer.
I did. And then from there,
something difficult happen in life,
which everyone should read the book.
I'm not going to give everything away.
You went through something difficult and
that's kind of how you found spin. Yes.
Um,
I,
it's interesting because no matter
what you do in life and you know,
whether you were a musician or a dancer
or anything growing up and no matter
what path your career takes,
it's,
it's so interesting in retrospect
what you bring to your career that you
might've learned when you were
eight years old. And so for me with,
we were talking about
this today with dancing,
I was constantly in a dance
class and I saw how, um,
gratifying it was if
the dance teacher said,
great job Ruth are like beautiful Ruth
and that could just make my entire day.
And that's just an example of something
that I brought to the spin class because
as I said, we were talking about, um,
if someone says, great job charity,
that's all you need and it gives you
almost a high for the rest of the day.
And so that was just one small component
of this product that came to be where
at the end of the day people felt better
about themselves after 45 minutes.
So how does your method
different than the,
when you started taking spin at,
I was at a Ribeye, the river club.
So is your method kind of the instructor
that you fell in love with their,
they're really motivated you
and kept you coming back or yes.
You're kind of your own on top of,
well it started with the method of the
instructor who became my guru. And um,
we were also talking about that phenomenon
where you go to an exercise class and
you just really become
obsessed with one instructor.
And then I did with this particular
instructor in two years in,
he got up in front of the class one day
and he announced that he was moving to
Florida and I was like,
how am I going even continue with my life?
And um,
that was the moment when I decided I,
I was just going to start teaching
because I didn't like any of the other
instructors.
And I had a background obviously in dance
and I had taught some group exercise
before that. So, um, I,
so I started teaching and then my five
years of teaching and Reebok is when I
really kind of honed my method and
added on to what he taught me and really
spent the time observing what
people liked, what they didn't like,
what they took to what motivated them.
And those were really the
formative years of my class.
And then from there you formed full
cycle I did with Elizabeth and Julie.
And how long did that take from the
thought of you guys wanting to have a spin
class over your own?
Cause you noticed that people that
were going into rework to take spin,
we're only taking spin exactly that
you wanted to kind of, you guys,
I feel like we're the pioneers
of this boutique fitness. Yes.
That you wanted to start this
from like when you thought of it,
how long did it take
to come off the ground?
So, um, the fall of 2005,
Elizabeth, uh, approached me. She
was a writer in my class and said,
I want to open up a dedicated boutique
fitness studio that only has spin and are
you interested? I know nothing
about spin. I would love it to be,
I would love you to be the face of the
business and have it be all about your
method and the way you teach. And
what do you think? And I mean,
within a nanosecond I was like,
I'm in. Um, it was a dream of mine.
I didn't have the, the, um,
capital to fund it. She did.
And, um, so that was in the fall.
And then eventually Julie, who
was also a writer, my class
was always interested in opening,
has been in business.
And she and I used to talk
about it all the time,
but neither one of us had the budget,
the money to do it.
So I am a very loyal person.
And I felt bad that it was Elizabeth
and I, and there was Julie.
So I introduced Julie to
Elizabeth thinking she'd be
a great third partner and
they headed off, hit it off. And
in answer to your question, um,
we started really formulating our,
our ideas in probably December and we
opened our doors in April of 2006 so not
that long.
Yeah. Yeah. And then it builds Romana men,
then there was a dissolution
of partnership. Correct.
And you still taught there for a
couple of years after and then you were
approached by two other writers.
Yes.
And then fly will was kind of born,
which I'm very happy about. Thank you.
I flywheel. So how did that, you know,
leaving soul cycle to
go found a competitor?
How did that happen?
So, uh, with the way things
went down at soul cycle,
I was very ready to leave. And um, I met,
as you said, one of my future cofounders
who was in my class, excuse me,
the other one didn't he never class,
but he was his partner.
They were both in private equity and
basically they saw this business in soul
cycle and saw the frogs of people coming
in and sat and crunched the numbers one
day and said surreal business
and wanted to get in on it.
And so Jay, one of them, um,
he is the one that came up with the idea
of attaching a little computer screen
to all the bikes where
you can be accountable,
where you could know where your resistance
should be, what your speech should be.
And they found me and
presented this idea to me.
And initially I was a little
dubious because I thought,
you know, so much of my ride was
about riding, closing your eyes,
going inside,
tapping into what was going on,
tapping into the song on the playlist, a
memory, whatever it was. And I thought,
well, now if we have
numbers, I don't know,
it's distracting and then we
can't really do the mind thing.
And so I wasn't really sure. And
they said, well, just, just try it.
Go into a room by yourself with
the bike and see what you think.
And that's what I did.
And within 15 minutes I was like,
this is genius.
And um,
the other thing that was so exciting about
it was it just became such an obvious
differentiator between what was
to become flywheel and soul cycle.
So here we were starting
second in the market,
but it was such a different product that
I absolutely knew there would be room
for it. So how was it trying to, I guess,
change your teaching method because
soul cycle is so different? Um,
was it more difficult when you had to
add in metrics and teach by numbers and
did that affect how you taught at all?
It definitely changed the class
that I had started at soul cycle,
but I was able to still
incorporate some mind,
body connection stuff with the metrics.
And I so quickly realized that it
was such a game changer in terms of,
as I said,
being accountable.
And then what happened was I started
seeing the results in people's bodies in
there, um, joy and
gratification that they,
they got from this kind of class with
these kind of, um, realtime results.
And so I was a fan, you
know, from the get go.
I read an article that said the difference
between people that ride at soul
cycle and fly wheel are that,
um,
five will people are masochists.
I me, I know some masochistic, I should,
I feel it's very type a it out to your
board is definitely why I'm a huge fan of
it.
So how do you pick your playlist or is
it just like your mood or is it based on
the numbers we get in
class or how do you decide
it's so instinctual.
A music always has always been
a really huge part of my life,
especially being a dancer.
Um, growing up, you know,
I don't know, music was my escape. I
had a kind of very difficult mother,
which I talk about in the book.
And, uh, when things got tough,
I would go on my room and listen to music.
And I ended up really learning a lot
about all different kinds of genres of
music,
um,
through my father and the music that was
always played in my household growing
up and dancing obviously.
And so making the playlist was such a
huge part of my enjoyment in what I do.
It's just I spend an enormous amount of
time making my playlist too much time.
Um, but I love it. And
so very mood driven. Um,
I would typically make a playlist for my
class the night before and then I would
wake up in the morning and leave myself
time because I would completely change
it the next morning. So again,
way too much time spent on it,
but it ended up,
you know,
bringing very successful playlists
that people really liked. And um,
making them eclectic was
really important too.
So hopefully there was something
for everyone in the class.
So now you had,
then you had flywheel and you and David
and Jay were cranking along and it
started to become successful.
And then Lou Frankford became a
series B investor and three Theo.
Okay.
Um,
how did that change the dynamics of
when it was the startups to then kind of
becoming a bigger brand?
How did that change?
Did it change how you taught or the
dynamics of the relationships within that
you had with the instructors? Or in
general, cause I know when Google,
obviously I've heard people talk about
when they were here before it became
public, the difference in the culture
and when you become this giant company,
which fly will not list.
Yes, huge change. Um,
Lou initially became a strategic
investors. Seriously. Um,
and when that happened,
the change wasn't felt that
obviously because we were all there.
David and Jay were there and we were
still, Lou had input on decisions,
but we were still making
most of the decisions.
It wasn't until 2014 when Lou and his
family acquired the business that things
really changed. So, you know,
within the first two months,
my two co founders were out.
And that in itself was a
huge adjustment for me. And,
um, it changed, the culture
changed drastically. And you know,
suddenly,
I mean,
my original office that I shared
with Jay wasn't electrical closet.
And, um, I mean we couldn't even back up
our chairs without hitting each other,
but it didn't matter. We didn't
care. Um, and then this happened, um,
the company was acquired and suddenly
we're in offices that are a city block.
And the whole culture changed in that
it just became much more corporate.
So I suddenly was in this environment
where I didn't even understand the
language. It was kind of like, um,
I'd be at a meeting and they'd
ask us to turn in our, um,
hold on our strategic operative
initiatives and I'd be like,
what? Like I had no idea
what they're talking about.
And then someone whisper to me, it just
means what's your plan? And then I felt,
well, why don't they say that? Like I
didn't, it was just such a shock for me.
And, um, and it was a real
growing experience, um,
which we talked about too.
So what, um, what was it like,
I guess when after Lou took over,
you did talk about in the book that,
I'm trying to frame this correctly,
um, now that you were trying to be
forced into a different position,
but the expectations of what
your role were to be had changed.
Yes.
And where you really enjoyed teaching,
you are now kind of pushing this business
role and that didn't really make you
happy.
Correct. Um, I found the whole,
I found all the changes to be intimidating
because it was just so out of my
comfort zone. And right
from the Gecko. Um,
Lou kind of wanted to mold me in a very
different way and suddenly my days were
spent in meetings after meetings
and a lot of talking and,
you know, ideas, but, but ideas that
weren't necessarily being executed,
but we would just keep having more
meetings. And I went into this business,
it exactly for the exact reason that I
didn't want to be sitting in a meeting
all day. And so it just became
really difficult. And, um,
I just stood up one day and I said,
this isn't working for me.
And I had no idea how they were gonna
react, but clearly they needed me.
So they were open to what
I had to say. And, um,
through that process, I really ended
up going back to what I did best,
which was being in charge of
everything that went on in the,
in the four walls of the studio
and, you know, training instructors,
teaching classes,
um,
being back in charge of the method
and kind of all things creative.
And that's,
that was my happy place.
So I did through a series
of events get back there.
So the other kind of focus on the book
that I really liked was you again talked
about a lot of personal things,
the relationship that you had
with your mother and your father.
That was kind of a triangle, this triangle
theme I noticed a lot in the book.
So it goes from your
mother to your father,
then with your husband and Felipe,
then Julie and Elizabeth.
Then David and Jay keep going.
And your twin daughters and their friends.
Is this,
um, have you noticed this a lot? Like,
and when you're attracted
to certain situations,
if there's some kind of trio that happens,
apparently that is what
happens. And um, you know,
as I also talk to
about in the book,
I started therapy long time
ago when I was 35 and I'm 60,
I'll be 61 in March. Um, so
I've had a lot of years in,
in terms of learning about myself and I
certainly am more aware than ever of the
triangles and really hope
I don't have any more.
I really hope so.
What I'm,
what I really enjoyed is
you, um, definitely were not,
you were not afraid to talk
about uncomfortable things
and how you reinvented
yourself. And it really how at any
age you can do that. If you're happy,
you're unhappy with something,
you can change it.
And if you're passionate about something,
if you follow that,
things will just kind of fall into place.
Which I felt like it
happened a lot with you. Um,
do you have any advice for other
entrepreneurs who are looking to start a
business?
I do. I think, you know,
we all want to do that now.
We all want to be entrepreneurs and
come up with the next great idea.
And you know,
this concept of finding your passion is,
is spoken about a lot.
And I think I always like to tell people
that you just don't sit down one day
and find your passion it.
Um,
and sometimes it comes to
you when you least expect it.
And after I gave up dancing,
which had been my passion my whole life,
starting from age eight,
I never in a million years thought I
would ever be passionate about something
else.
And the reason why I found
spin was really because,
um,
through a lot of years I just tried to
be open to all kinds of experiences and a
lot of those experiences more negative
and didn't work for me. You know,
I tried to work in an office and, uh, as
an office manager at a catering company,
cause I was interested in food.
I did that after I gave up dancing cause
I had no idea what I was going to do.
And you know what? I hated
it. And I learned that I
don't want to sit at a desk.
So that was informative. Um, after I,
as I was going through the
trauma of my divorce, I, um,
that's when I found spinning and I decided
one day again to just head into that
kind of intimidating feelings,
Spin Room at the gym I belong to,
um, after several weeks of walking back
and forth. And should I or shouldn't I?
And one day, I don't know, something in
me said, oh, just go in there and try it.
And I did. And that was when I found
spinning. But there was a lot in between.
And so I just think it's important to
have faith and know that you will find it
and uh,
it might not happen when you expect it to.
So you
recently left flywheel and very recently,
which I saw in December.
What are you most
excited to get into next?
Or is it just kind of open ended?
Big Breath? Um, so I'm in
my noncompete period now,
so I can't really talk about what's next
and I don't know definitively what it
is I'm trying to.
Right now my process is about having
actually lots of meetings with different
kinds of people and um,
figuring out what people want,
what's people still desire,
you know, we're in this age of
everything going digital obviously,
and people working out by
themselves in their home,
which is really kind of the opposite of,
of what I've always done.
And so I'm getting, you know, a lot of
gathering a lot of information about,
you know,
how much of a desire is there still a
for the group experience and working out
together in building a
community, um, you know,
studying trends right now and,
and letting that kind of helped
me get to that next decision.
So I really don't know yet, but, um,
it will be in fitness of course, cause
that's what I do best. And uh, we'll see.
It's exciting.
Um, touching on that a little bit
about working at, at home, um,
I read in the book that the owner or
the person that kind of invented Peloton
yes.
Approached you guys about partnering and
was it Lou that didn't want to go for
it? It was wow. I mean, Miss, yes.
Right.
Yeah.
Specifically said if we're
going to get into that business,
we'll do it ourselves. Um, and
that's, that was his belief. So yes.
Do what, what are your feelings on
the working out alone or, you know,
having the interactive class as
opposed to being in the room? I mean,
I know how I feel about it. Yeah. Um,
look,
I feel like obviously it was
great opportunity for John and,
um,
he's done incredibly well.
The company's valued at 4 billion.
I think at this they're adding treading.
I just thought I'd have a treadmill.
Yeah. And opponents as well. So, um,
obviously there's a market
for it and a need for it. Um,
I still firmly believe that there are
enough people out there who want the group
experience.
And truthfully,
so much of the success of both soul cycle
and fly wheel was the building of this
exceptional community.
And the community obviously consists
of people sharing in this experience
together and personally,
and I could be wrong.
I just feel that in this day and age of
so much disconnection and working out
alone or being on our
phones all day, I, I,
I feel like human connection
will never really out of style.
And I think it's always a need,
an innate need for us. And
I feel for that reason there
will always be a market and uh,
enough people out there who want to kind
of go back to that and they feel that,
I'm just going to say it,
I feel like in this huge expansion that
occurred for flywheel and soul cycle,
I think a lot of that got lost.
A lot of the community and that
high touch customer service.
And so I kind of feel like there
is a need to bring it back.
And I do think that things go in full
circles. So I'm thinking a lot about that.
Yeah.
Yeah. I definitely think that there's a
lot more energy that you get when you're
physically in the class and working
out at home. I just personally for me,
if, if I'm more accountable
when I have people around me,
then it's just me by myself.
Um,
and I think a great instructor
also motivates you when
you're physically looking
at them and they call out your
name like we talked about.
It motivates you to push
even more to really,
really getting the
uncomfortable place. Um, right.
Because it's the connection you have
with the instructor and you will go very
far for that one instructor. Yes.
It's amazing. It's amazing that,
um,
I feel your brand or brands because soul
cycle like that I know really popular
instructors or classes we'll book up
the second that it opens and people will
pay extra to have the early
bookings for that reason. And um,
I feel like flywheels this a
different kind of experience. Um,
and I,
um,
it's more motivating to me when I have a
really good instructor I think keeps me
accountable physically in class
and I would by myself at home.
I agree. Yeah. Yeah. So I'm
just some fun stuff now. Um,
and the book you talk about,
you know,
being able to travel more
after your children were
older and you guys have trips
that you take together and
how much you love to eat,
which is also why you enjoy,
you know, working out so much.
What is been kind of your,
obviously I'm really into food.
We talked about this as well.
What has been your most favorite
kind of food experience?
Um,
I mean,
I'm not sure there was this a specific
one, but because my partner and I,
we're both equally into
to eating good food.
Literally every business
trip we would take,
the first thing we would do is check out
the best restaurants in whatever city
we went to. So, so it was great.
So I had great dining experiences
in every city I went to. Um,
yeah,
I mean the whole premise of flywheel
because of he and I was all about working
hard,
playing hard and we were never
about deprivation or you know,
cut out this,
cut out that from your diet.
It was all about kind of
eating whatever you want,
drinking and just working out hard on
the fly wheel bike the next day you can't
account. And that was our
mantra. So yeah. So it was just,
I mean it was one of the reasons
why traveling with so much fun,
it's because we got to experience so
many different kinds of restaurants.
Um,
when you guys are,
when you were a part of flywheel stow
and you were looking for instructors,
was there some kind of personality trait
or like what struck you about who you
want it to bring in to teach?
We certainly hired instructors
who like to work hard and um,
motivate that way by being,
as we said, um, aspirational.
That was our word.
When we were looking for an instructor,
they had to be aspirational,
whether it was, um,
because of their own physical prowess or,
um,
a certain x factor that was so
important that is so important in every
instructor.
And that was actually a part of the
personality that was really hard to train.
They kind of either had to have
it or they weren't hireable.
So again,
some dynamic in their personality
that could draw a rider in, you know,
on top of their physical strength.
Um, now I know that fly will recently,
maybe in the past couple of years added,
um, they give us previously called
fly beats. Now it's called tempo.
And that is similar ish to soul cycle,
but it just has a little more
resistance than soul cycle tests. Um,
was there,
is that kind of the reason you added that
and for people who were more drawn to
that kind of method but also
wanted the metrics to go with it.
So that was a really interesting
learning lesson. And the reason is yes,
we decided to add it because it
was more about a rhythm ride,
which is how the soul cycle ride is based.
And we thought,
well we should add it and then we can
cast our net wider and hopefully drawn
some of those writers who specifically
like that kind of ride. Um,
what I realized in retrospect was I kind
of regretted it because I feel like do
what you do well and really represent the,
um,
specialness of your product and your
ride and don't feel that you have to get
everyone there. There are enough
people out there, you know,
especially in big urban cities,
New York, obviously. Um,
there are enough people out there to
fill your rooms and why not just really
stick to what you do best.
And, um, and it just, yeah,
it started to kind of dilute the product
and I wasn't really crazy about the
idea to be honest with you.
How did you decide which locations
you would add it in to try it out?
Just the bigger city.
Our initial,
uh,
way of identifying locations was
just open next to a whole foods.
It really was,
that was her formula open
next to whole foods and it always works.
Um,
we did mostly choose urban areas.
We did, however, um, what we would
do is we'd find an urban area,
a spot next to a whole
foods. And then, um,
we would open in a suburb close to the,
the initial,
um,
studio so that we could farm out our
instructors and they could actually teach
at both locations. And it was a great
way to utilize our instructor team.
So we did add suburban locations as well.
They,
there were exceptions, but,
um, they, some did really well.
Some didn't. Um, we just
found the formula of,
we found it much safer to
open in urban areas, um,
more than suburban areas. And, um,
I think that in urban for some
reason in some suburban areas,
even if they were wealthy areas,
people didn't want to spend money
as much as they do in, in the city.
And that was an interesting
learning experience as well.
I was just going to say
when I just thought of this,
when we opened in Scarsdale for example,
you know,
I didn't think about the fact that,
and I learned this from our Scarsdale
writers. Um, they would say to me,
we don't want to Pay New York prices.
That's why we moved to Scarsdale.
And it was like, oh, that makes sense.
Um, they would complain all the time.
What,
um,
what has been your most
favorite experience that
you've been able to do because
of flywheel or in soul cycle? Like
something that you'd wear, like wow,
I can't believe this is
happening. Writing the book. Yeah.
I never in a million years
thought I would ever be an author,
but ironically,
and this kind of is consistent
with staying open to things. Um,
when I was going through,
I went through my divorce and I was really
a fish out of water and have no idea
what I was going to do in my life.
And I decided to take a course in
memoir writing completely randomly.
Um, I knew that I always liked to write
but just thought, oh, that'll be fun.
And so it's,
I never again in a million years thought
I would ever write a book or a memoir,
but it was just maybe that
was foreshadowing. I Dunno.
Thank you so much for coming. You're
welcome. Thank you for that early set.
Such a great time talking with you today.
I'm going to open it up for questions
now if you want to walk up to the
microphones.
Thank you so much for coming. Huge. Yeah,
I'd love to hear more about
the relationship dynamics
of your cofounders at soul
cycle cause it sounds like
you were approached by Juan
and that had brought the
other one in and then sort of you
wound up out of the mix and having uh,
founded a startup where we had a
cofounder breakup. I'm over time.
I'm just interested to learn,
like how did you,
what were the things that you were,
what went wrong and sort of what were
the things you were looking for the next
time when you started
the flywheel and maybe
even moving on now,
like what are some of the things that
are top of line as you think about your
next venture?
Great question. I have to be a little
careful about what exactly happened,
uh, on that day at soul
cycle. But, um, in retrospect,
I've really learned a lot about the
dynamic that the three of us had and the
mistakes that were made on my part.
And it's been such a growing experience
for me learning through these mistakes
and as I talk about in the book,
um,
and his charities so aptly pointed
out the whole triangle thing,
which started with my parents,
um,
really was replicated in that
business partnership. Um,
and I ended up being comfortable in a
role that unfortunately was comfortable
for me, which was a role of
kind of taking the back seat,
kind of being overpowered, being, um,
what felt like bullied.
Um,
and
quite frankly, not being strong
enough at various points of the,
of my time. It's all cycle, not being
strong enough to stand up for myself. And,
um,
ultimately it worked against me and um,
I certainly had a lot of
learning experiences to bring
to my next partnership at
flywheel. That was
drastically different. Um,
so as I talk about that
question in the book, it's,
it's really about self awareness and
doing the work to get to know yourself
however that plays,
however that workplace out and not
repeating patterns and not making the same
mistakes.
Hi there.
Hi.
Another huge fan you got me through
like my pregnancy and every and the last
eight. Awesome. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you so much. You're welcome.
And I travel a lot for work
and I oftentimes find myself
booking hotels that are
closer to fly occasions because I know
that even in the change of my routine,
I still get the experience
I want in cardio.
And you still feel like New York and
the energy you need for the day. Um,
can you talk a little bit about how
the expansion strategy worked with also
making sure that you had the same
culture and energy and type of trainers?
They do differ a bit
occasions. Yes. Asian. Um,
but how you keep the consistency of the
brand with such a massive expansion.
Yeah,
so I'm not going to lie. It's, and
you actually just pointed it out when,
when the expansion got to a certain
point and it was really big.
It was hard.
It's hard to maintain the culture
and up until a certain point,
um,
we were able to maintain it and I
really feel that change happened.
Um,
when we were taking over and when we
were acquired at that point we had 22
studios, which still a lot.
Um, and I always say this,
it's not rocket science.
My partner and I, Jay, um,
our third partner kind of stayed in the
background and did more a real estate
and finance.
But Jay and I were in the forefront and
I was the face and Jay was in operations
and really ran the business.
And as simple as this sounds,
Jay and I were both are both
very nice people and um,
we have unfortunately we both had this
quality where we really need to be liked
by everybody, which is not
always a really great quality,
but we both had it.
And so there's such a trickle down
phenomenon that happens from the top.
And as a result we just amassed
this amazing group of people.
And it also had a lot to do with
how we treated our employees and we,
we considered our employees to
be as important as our customers.
And it didn't matter what your role was,
it didn't matter if you were
mopping floors or your a senior VP.
Um, everybody was treated the same.
And I think that because of that,
we just ended up, you
know, really great, nice,
wonderful people gravitated to us
and want it to work with us. And,
and that's why we would always call
it the fly family, the fly fam,
because we all really felt like a family.
But no question.
As we expanded and they
expand expansion continued.
That's what I talked about before where,
um,
that specialness kind of,
you know, was compromised.
I also love studying all
things fitness trends.
So love that your internet as well.
What are some of the studios or concepts
or things that you're really looking at
that are doing it right right now and
as you're thinking about your future,
what insights do you think you
would want to take from them?
So it's interesting because when I hear
about other successful boutique fitness
businesses,
we were talking about rumble for example,
the ones that I hear a lot of
excitement about our, again,
the ones where people are,
are gravitating toward the community.
And so I've heard that a lot about rumble.
And um,
there was actually a
really interesting article,
I don't know if you guys saw that
came out recently. Inbox. And she,
the writer talked about,
um,
this concept of expansion and how,
she talks a lot about flywheel
and soul cycle and um,
talk to about her opinion was that they
kind of lost their focus and identity
and she spent a lot of time talking about
boutique and how the smaller studios
that are coming up now are actually
doing better and people are going back to
that.
And so I found that really interesting
terms of trends and things going full
circle. But, um,
I hear a lot about rumble boxing seems
to really be taking, taking on. Um,
I do feel that,
you know,
things have changed so much since the
days of soul cycle starting and flywheel
starting. Um, and I'm about to
lose my train of thought. Um,
I know. And so what's
been happening, again,
the whole full circle thing is a lot of
these boutique businesses that started
boutique started out as,
but boutique have now expanded
their modalities and um, you know,
a flywheel or soul cycle started adding
a lot of different kinds of classes.
And now we see a lot of these studios
with five different offerings. And,
and in a sense that feels
to me like, oh, so the,
the what started out as a very dedicated
boutique business has now actually
morphed into the big box gym, which
is how we started in the first place.
So if I were to start again,
um,
spoiler alert. Um, and I don't, you
know, I haven't committed to anything,
but I think that if I did
start a brick and mortar,
if I did do another brick and mortar,
it would never be about one offering,
which is what it could be about initially.
But I probably have too.
And that would be it. I wouldn't want
to make it any bigger than that. And,
um,
as I said before,
I think that the community aspect and
that connecting with people is never going
to fall out of favor.
You're welcome,
but said right.
I thought it was interesting and it made
me look really good, so I liked that.
Hi. Hi. First of all, thank you for making
an android APP. Finally. That was awesome.
You're welcome. Um, I have two questions.
One is what is your personal fitness
routine? Are you still spinning?
Do you teach? And my
second question is, um,
there's a lot of new trends in terms of
virtual reality where bikes are actually
moving in the rooms or music videos.
Do you think those are all
gimmicks or are they actually, uh,
contributing something to the,
and so it's hard to answer that
without my own personal, uh, opinion.
I, you know, for myself, I,
they do seem gimmicky to me.
It's just my opinion. Um, I,
you know, I left, as I said,
I left flywheel December 31st,
but up until December 31st I was
teaching six to seven classes a week.
Um,
I can't ever imagine not teaching.
It's just what I do and I
love it and it never gets old.
And sourcing to charity.
I've been teaching on,
I've been on a bike for
21 years. Um, sadly,
I hate to even talk about this,
but I am a nursing,
a back injury right now.
So a lower back injury.
So for the first time in 2021 years,
I'm off the bike and I'm not doing
anything except going to physical therapy.
So,
um,
it'll be interesting to see if anything
changes being off the bike. I mean,
I think one of the reasons why I've been
such an advocate for spending is that
it's actually so safe and it's low impact
and people can do it at any age and
you know, so whatever's going
on in my back, you know,
maybe it's a overuse and just
long term kind of situation.
Hopefully it'll get better soon.
But at the same time I am an advocate
to mixing it up and not just doing,
doing one modality.
Um,
I was doing SLT for a while and I
enjoyed that. It's so challenging. Um,
and then of late,
I've been incorporating Pilati into my
routine because I think politics is so
challenging, but really
effective. I want to ask about
the book, which is your newest baby. And
what I'm fascinated by is obviously you,
you've left an amazing legacy,
but also as a business woman who's done
very well as you were thinking about the
book and all the many things you can
write about and I'm sure you had an eye on
kind of the business aspect of
what is the most interesting,
how do you get the most viewers
and readers and whatnot?
How did you decide what to cover in the
book and what to emphasize on and how to
position it?
The beginning,
I'm sorry,
the genesis of the book really happened
by me just sitting down and starting to
write personal anecdotes.
That's how I started it. Um,
I worked with a collaborator because I
really didn't know how to start and she
posed that to me.
She said,
what about sitting down and writing
10 stories that come to mind,
uh, through the course of your life?
And, and so that's how I started.
And so it really started,
I think from a personal place.
And then I was quickly able to draw
lessons from personal experiences,
lessons that I learned in life and,
and then applied them to business.
So that's kind of how that theme happened.
And it really,
you know,
came the whole idea to do it that way.
Just happened really organically
and really easily. And again,
it made,
it was very consistent with me because
I am all about not being afraid of
sharing personal stories and
that's how I connect with people.
So it just made sense. More organic
versus like a market research. Absolutely.
Much more organic, which again made sense
for me since no business experience.
And I don't have another question. I just
want to say you look amazing. Thank you.
Oh,
I have to say I was a little disappointed
because usually it comes out in my
talks that I'm 60 and it usually
gets a huge response. Guys were like,
yeah, whatever. So thank you.
Are there any more questions?
I'll hear air.
I'm also nursing an injury and I'm
of daytime runner, so I said, oh,
how terrible that and
disruptive in your life.
[inaudible] and PG. So sand.
But, um, I wanted to like,
learn a little bit more
about the marketing aspect
of the flywheel brand. Um,
I'm an ad sales here at Google and
I always think it's interesting,
especially in a super competitive
environment like fitness,
especially with the rise of social media
and just all of the community aspects
of it.
But how do you still make paid advertising
and paid marketing really work for
your brand and actually drive results?
So I'd love to hear more about that.
Sure. So, um,
we never advertised ever this business,
so word of mouth, um, we never
needed two things have changed now.
Um, and it's interesting,
uh, marketing and branding.
When we, I remember specifically
when we started flywheel,
we really had no idea what our
brand was going to look like.
And people would say, well, what's your
brand? And my partner and I would say,
I don't, we don't know. Um,
and we just started the business and
the brand came to us and you know,
through kind of trial and error. And it
was just a way to figure out who we were.
And then we actually hired a marketing
team to work with us about a year in and
they were the ones who came up with the
idea of never coast. And I, we love that.
And so that really became
a game changer for us.
And that was something we could really,
um,
hang on to and build
a marketing plan from.
Yeah.
I have a question about like the pricing
and how you came up with that because
soul cycle,
uh,
to me it seems like one of the first
kind of boutique or the most well known
early boutique places and like I was
wondering how you guys came up with like
the pricing strategy and having no
memberships and stuff like this at a gym.
And then if you like if
it was like a conscious,
this isn't a change of mind
when going to fly wheel.
I'm just basically wondering like how did
you know that people are going to want
to pay like this type of money
to do a boutique fitness class?
Cause it doesn't really seem like
people were doing that before.
Purely ripped it off from
cell cycle. We did. I mean,
we just used,
looked at their model as to how
they priced and replicated it.
We knew that they were getting it because
the business was booming at that point
when I left. And, um, and so
that's how we did it. However,
over time we changed, um, our, our, um,
strategy because they became in through
their pricing even more elitist.
And we really wanted to
move away from that. I mean,
they offered their supersoul for
$70 for 45 minutes spin class.
And we see that just wasn't us,
it wasn't our identity.
And we really wanted to,
um,
build a business that was
about inclusiveness and soul
cycle to us seemed like a
business that was about
exclusiveness. So that, um,
was very important in how
we went about our pricing.
I personally was not in charge
of that part of the business,
so I can't speak with too
much detail about it, but, um,
I know that the membership idea
really took off for us and was,
and people love the membership because
they could really get in a lot of classes
for a lot less money. Well,
thank you. You're welcome.
What I do love is that you give
this Ben shoes for free rental,
whereas soul cycle, I think it was like
three or $4. Yeah. And water. Yeah.
For one as well.
Yeah.
Which is great because you don't have
to bring anything with you, which is it
amazing.
And that was another way in which we
started the business and figure it out.
Things was obviously I was
coming from soul cycle.
And so what better way than for
me to look back on soul cycle and,
and know what worked and what didn't
work and the things that worked we,
we kept and the things that didn't work,
we changed.
And one of the things I knew from the
rider experience was they would come to
take class and then,
oh,
they'd have to take out their wallet
again to pay for water or take out their
wallet to pay for shoes.
And they really kind of resented it.
So that was just one example of how we
thought we're going to do away with that.
And one last question.
Okay, good. Last question.
So we have spins to you on the 14th floor.
I saw it once.
You're back gets back in order.
Are the chances you come and teach us?
I was actually thinking about that.
I really, we can help organize.
Oh yeah, I'll do it. No,
I'm actually wondering if like
that would interfere with my
noncompete. But I mean, come on
Tony, while anybody, okay, I'm here.
I'm not at work cause I never got to
take your class. I would love to do it.
Thank you for inviting me.
I'm Ruth will be upstairs
to sign books after,
so if everyone wants to Q upstairs,
she'll be finding things and you can
buy the book and thank you so much for
coming. [inaudible] patch a
pleasure meeting you. Thank you.